did you find out that you were unable to
run for election
hey Sophie good morning um I got an
email an email said thank you for
replying
um you are unsuccessful to be taken
forward as a candidate
uh so yeah you know I've been mayor
since 2019 as you said
um this so the area I cover is expanding
it will bring in other parts we'll be
covering the wider Northeast
um I've delivered thousands of jobs I've
built affordable homes I've implemented
a grin New Deal we're tackling child
poverty across 90 schools in the region
and expanding that so when it comes to
what the labor party needs to project to
win elections which is economic
competence I've got a fantastic track
record and for members not to be allowed
the choice
of putting me forward as the labor
representative is is frankly shocking
and I've had so much support from right
across the political Spectrum so what I
want is for for Kieran the labor party
to do nothing more than give members the
choice of choosing me as their candidate
so you've got the email uh saying that
your application has been unsuccessful
surely you must have known before that
that this was going to happen
um well no you can't notice you get the
email because because that's the the
decision being told
um so you go through a process you talk
to the NEC panel
um and we said look there's no issue
with your competence there is no issue
with anti-Semitism they were very very
clear about that and they said it's an
issue that because you spoke to Ken
Loach
um that may causes electoral damage in
future was their argument I said if you
think Labor's going to lose an election
because I spoke to Ken Loach it was a
really successful filmmaker and he just
produced the film in the Northeast and I
was asked as part of the celebrations
for the live theater
would you have a conversation with Ken
Loach so yeah of course if it's just
about his films which it was and that
was it you know so that's one hour of my
last four years as mayor so the not let
members have the choice and make that
decision of do they want me to be their
candidate to me seems wholly
disproportionate if that is the reason
but that's not the reason they don't
they don't give the reasons
I mean labor say that that was the
reason that you were not allowed to run
because as you say you did share a
platform with Ken loach
you say that it was just about the films
that he made but at the same time this
is somebody who's been you know expelled
from the party and I do just want to
read you some of the things that
kenloach has said because when he was
asked uh if a discuss in a discussion
about whether or not the Holocaust
happened was unacceptable he said that
history is for all of us to discuss the
founding the state of Israel for example
based on ethnic cleansing is there for
us all to discuss the role of Israel now
is there for us all to discuss so don't
try and subvert that with false stories
of anti-Semitism that was when he was
asked whether or not a discussion on
whether the Holocaust happened would be
acceptable he's also said that the
actions of the state of Israel make
increasing anti-Semitism understandable
he said if there has been a rise I'm not
surprised in fact it's perfectly
understandable because Israel feeds
feelings of anti-semitism
I mean surely you can see why sharing a
platform with canloach may be
problematic
if no if you want to ask Ken about his
views then do that I'm not a
spokesperson for Ken Loach
um and let's be really clear
um that my combined Authority Under My
leadership has adopted the I ihra
definition of anti-semitism and
references the examples I've been on
Jewish labor movement um training
um I work very closely with the Jewish
Leadership Council visit the synagogues
in my region so this is an entirely
separate issue about Ken loach's issues
you need to take up weekend lotion I'm
not a spokesperson
um but he's produced that there's only
been three feature films set in the
Northeast in a couple of decades I'm
Daniel Blake sorry we missed you and now
the old oak and so it is a big cultural
significant issue for the Northeast and
to talk to him about films I think is
entirely Justified I share platforms
with all sorts of people a couple of
weeks ago I was on the platform with Ben
hugeon that does not mean I endorse the
Tories economic policies
at the same time so you don't regret
sharing a platform with kennel hm and
I've regret this entire episode now the
whole thing's blowing up and now labor
members are not getting the opportunity
you don't think it was wrong of you to
share a platform with Ken loach
and I think the issues of
speaking to somebody about something
entirely different from a controversial
issue
um and you know my understanding is that
he's made all sorts of clarifications
and he's not a holocaust tonight I think
he wrote a letter to the New York Times
explicitly saying that the Holocaust was
a real event which of course it was so I
honestly Sophie I think we've got to get
the proportionality here what the public
wants from their politicians is to get
on with things and deliver things and
not to engage in culture wars
cancel culture or anything like that I
actually think that's electorally
damaging
I guess some people might say that
you know when
issues of anti-Semitism within the labor
party led to a big distrust by the
Jewish Community kirstan is trying to
rebuild that trust that you sharing a
platform with Ken Loach who you know
I've read out some of the things that he
said when it comes to anti-Semitism when
it comes to Israel and the Holocaust
and you don't really think that is
problematic you think it's right that
you talk to them about the films I think
we should let the members make that
decision
let's trust the labor party members to
say do we think that Jamie's done a good
job as Matt do we think he'd win as an
election do we think actually is an
electoral asset
um and I would think you would find that
Yes actually would be the result there's
a pattern of behavior here I think that
people who support renationalization of
the utilities who support stronger
workers rights of being excluded at lots
of stages in the labor party whether
that's standing as MPS whether that's
frequently as countless people being
deselected I've spoken to Mayors and
peace people who are ministers in the
new labor administrations all of whom
are really worried The Sword of Damocles
is hanging above them and they're going
to be next
so you think this is about factualism in
the labor party effectively Kirsten were
purging the left
I think there's a big issue if you look
at what's happened
um if you look at you know some of the
things that have happened to me recently
um is a sitting mat I should
automatically be allowed to contact
members I was asking for this for about
two years and got um it finally got an
email from the regional director saying
because you are a potential candidate in
a future election we can't give you it
everybody's a potential candidate I find
labor party staff ringing this is way
before I spoke to Ken about films
saying um you must disinvite Jamie
because there may be an event coming up
um where there's going to be a selection
for the labor candidate you know this is
um there is a big issue here about
democracy about should people be like
that's how we do elections in a
civilized country isn't it Sophie you
know you let people decide do they want
their candidate why should you bar
someone on the basis of that decision
I mean I guess you know just come back
to they would say that the borrowing is
because of their huge concerns about
taking a red line when it comes to
anti-Semitism and sharing platforms with
people uh in regards to that as well I
mean have you read the ehrc report into
anti-Semitism in the labor party you
talk about sharing the platform so yeah
if you um I done You'll Play the
question was about the ehrc report into
anti-Semitism if you read the report
so not the full report no I haven't um I
haven't read the full forward report
either
um yeah you've perhaps got to bear in
mind I'm not an opposition politician
I'm a labor mayor in power delivering my
focus is on doing good things for the
people in our region not internal labor
party management I'm not involved in
that in any sense at all really
um so you know from from 60 70 hours a
week I'm delivering jobs I'm building
homes I'm negotiating to get more money
in the region currently negotiating with
Pension funds to get an extra two
billion pounds of investment for us so
the labor party management stuff but
here's the kicker the labor party's
official position on Ken Loach is we do
not comment you know so you ask you you
check for clarification what's what's
the appropriate procedure and there
isn't one so how on Earth are you
supposed to avoid sharing a platform
with someone that later turns out should
be controversial
um this the general public will look at
this and think it's crazy they're
successful mayor that has huge
cross-party support
and labor members aren't even allowed
the choice to vote for him that's crazy
so what are your next steps is there any
sort of appeals process you can run for
another position
um well um I am still a labor party
member I'm still mayor for the next 11
months no matter what happens
um I would like Kia to have a look at
this
um I would like him to say look let's
let the members decide uh my Trade union
is backing they've got huge support from
across the party
um I I've had a look at the legal routes
it's not all clear what they are
um and then you know I really do think
that just let members choose who they
want as their candidates that's how
democracy works and I honestly think
here Sophie actually in a two-party
system if you're going to ban people who
are promoting socialist views from
participating in that that is really
quite anti-democratic